[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsminister claudia pana
mit der bürgermeister von wiener
neustadt klaus schneeberger und dem
kommandanten der theresianischen merke
wie ich genau wie kupfer und hagel und
ich darf die frau und mann ist den
linken zu beginnen
der geselle bürgermeister general
wasserkarte damen und herren immer
wieder schöne inderin neustadt zu sein
der bürgermeister heute freue ich mich
ganz besonders hier in den
räumlichkeiten der islamischen
militärakademie sein zu dürfen
diese wurde 17 51 gegründet mit dem
sicher bekannten auftrag von maria
theresia an den ersten kommandanten
macht mir süchtige offiziers und
rechtschaffene männer daraus mit diesem
auftrag wird bis heute nacht gekommen
und der theresianischen militärakademie
ist nicht nur die älteste
militärakademie der welt sondern auch
eine der besten und der generalmajor an
dieser stelle möchte ich nicht bei ihnen
und auch ganz besonders dafür bedanken
jedoch gibt es auch bei aller
schützenswerten tradition wer aufhört
besser zu werden hat aufgehört gut zu
sein und daher muss sich um sind
ungefähr und somit auch wird der
iranischen militär laufend verbessern
und auch verändern so wie wir unsere
streitkräfte auf die herausforderungen
der zukunft ausrichten
richten müssen so werden wir haben
unsere offiziere auf diese aufgaben
vorbereiten
dann haben wir uns entschieden neben der
bestehenden offiziersausbildung im
rahmen des bachelor studien lehrganges
militärischer führung einen zweiten
studiengang zu implementieren
das wintersemester 20 22 jetzt der
militärakademie und hier ist wichtig zu
betonen immer vorbehaltlich der
akkreditierung der agro austria der
studiengang militärische informations
und kommunikationstechnologie führung
angeboten mit diesem studiengang setzen
wir erneut trends und schaffen ohne
zweifel eine enorme qualitätssteigerung
im rahmen unserer offiziersausbildung in
summe wird die ausbildung zum ipo 44
jahre dauern
beginnen mit der charta anwärter
ausbildung werden erste soldatische
fähigkeiten erworben macht absolvieren
die aufnahmeprüfung werden
andere militärakademie absolviert
abgeschlossen des geheimdiensts leutnant
und dem akademischen grad bachelor of
arts im unterschied zu den klassischen
offizieren erhalten wie kde offiziere
neben der militärischen ausbildung eine
fundierte akademische ausbildung in den
bereichen programmierung die sicherheit
systemadministration kryptografie die kd
einsatzplanung und vielem mehr
diese ausbildung dieses ausbildung
findet in kooperation mit der fh wiener
neustadt start und ich möchte an dieser
stelle ein ganz großes dankeschön sein
bürgermeister der präsident film vielen
dank für diese gute zusammenarbeit für
diesen ausbildung lernen die
absolventinnen und absolventen werden
dann im anschluss im rahmen ihrer erst
verwendung frikadellen stellvertreter
der kompaniekommandanten einer
führungsunterstützung kompanie oder sie
übernehmen andere taktisch wichtige
führungsfunktionen im bereich der
elektronischen kampfführung sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir schließen damit
eine fähigkeit lücke für unser
bundesheer der zukunft absolventinnen
und absolventen des studiums haben einen
äußerst verhalten karrieren plattform
können ein ziviles masterstudium im ik t
bereich absolvieren aber zum beispiel
auch vor generalstabsoffiziere werden
sie sehen wir haben viel vor das geht
nur in einem miteinander liegen land
noch einmal an dieser stelle auch an sie
herr general
wir haben hier eine wirklich tolle
ausbildung entwickelt ich danke all
jenen die bei der entwicklung beteiligt
waren sehr geehrter herr bürger die ihre
werke auch ihnen ein großes dankeschön
ich freue mich bereits jetzt wenn wir
gemeinsam die ersten fähnriche dieses
studiums hier an der militärakademie
begrüßen dürfen
ein geschenk danke und bitte herr
bürgermeister
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister da kann
man dann der theresianischen
militärakademie meine geschätzten damen
und herren ich erinnere mich noch gut
zurück vor in etwa zwei jahrzehnten
haben wir einen slogan ausgegeben
nämlich wiener neustadt soll von der
stadt der rauchenden schlote zur stadt
der rauchenden köpfe werden und dieses
ziel haben wir sehr stringent in den
letzten 20 jahren verfolgt lassen sie
mich einige meilensteine zu diesem ziel
anführen
das technologie- und forschungszentrum
die fachhochschule wiener neustadt als
erster und groß größte fachhochschule in
österreich die fernfahrt die branche die
innovative unternehmen die sich in
wiener neustadt niedergelassen haben
ich erwähne schiebe der mont aircraft
zkw und viele andere mehr
vor allem auch das leuchtturmprojekt
metatron bis hin zum breitbandausbau in
der stadt der ja in wahrheit die basis
für innovative aktivitäten sind heute
mit dieser präsentation schließen wir
nahtlos an diese aktivitäten haben
offiziers ausbildung mit dem schwerpunkt
information und kommunikationstechnik
ist etwas was meines erachtens den
zeitgeist von heute unmittelbar trifft
und basis auch zur bekämpfung von cyber
angriffen als basis gesehen werden kann
damit der fährt die garnisonsstadt
wiener neustadt zu eine weitere
aufwertung und wenig sagt die
garnisonsstadt wiener neustadt eine
weitere aufwertung dann darf ich schon
eines feststellen die stadt wiener
neustadt und die militärakademie sind
ein seit jahrzehnten in wahrheit seit
jahrhunderten verbunden
verbunden mit gemeinsamen
veranstaltungen ich denke an die
ausmusterung als highlight jedes jahres
an die leistung schauen die hier geboten
werden aber auch ganz banale mit dem
menschen mit den bürgern verbundenen
aktivitäten nämlich die gestaltung
gemeinsame gestaltung des akademie
parkes aber auch die gemeinsame nutzung
des akademie bades auf lokal kehrte zur
bewerbung des minister leider ist es
üblich dass so mancher hier
ausgebildeter junger offizier uns die
jungen damen die wiener neustädter
rinnen und wiener neustadt weg nimmt das
positive ist dass sie meistens dann in
dieser stadt sich niederlassen und hier
wiener neustädter werden aber wieder zum
ernst der sache
ich habe ja auch den wirtschaftsstandort
den wird die wirtschafts bedeutung der
militärakademie vor augen geführt und
eines kann man sagen für den
arbeitsplatz und für die wirtschaft ist
diese militärakademie ein motor mehr als
600 arbeitskräfte sind hier tätig
und wenn ich die jungen kadettin ein und
kadetten vor mir sehe dann freut es mich
dass bereits 85 hier anwesend sind und
hier diese moderne handelsakademie als
ihre ausbildungsstätte sehen die frau
bundesminister kommt nicht mit leeren
händen nach wiener neustadt und ich darf
mich wirklich bedanken
gerade in zeiten wie diesen ist es
wichtig investitionen zu tätigen und
über die frau bundesminister hat mir im
vorfeld mitgeteilt dass in den nächsten
jahren 38 millionen euro in die
infrastruktur der militärakademie
investiert werden ein mehrzweckgebäude
und größere sanierungsaktivitäten sind
vorgesehen
dafür ein herzliches dankeschön aber
wenn ich schon beim danken bin dann darf
ich auf die aktuelle situation auch
eingehen auf die pandemie
ohne unterstützung des bundesheeres wäre
es uns nicht möglich gewesen
bis zum heutigen tag die entsprechenden
tests durchzuführen
sie müssen davon ausgehen dass wir mit
hilfe des bundesheeres 14 angehörige
haben uns laufend im assistenzeinsatz
unterstützt die massen tests durchführen
konnten die massen des im dezember im
jänner aber vor allem seit 27 jener
tagtäglich sie müssen davon ausgehen
dass wir wöchentlich an die 10.000 tests
durchführen
wir sind eine stark betroffene stadt von
der pandemie
daher ist dieser diese unterstützung
unbedingt notwendig gewesen um überhaupt
die möglichkeit zu haben diese tests
durchzuführen liebe frau bundesminister
generalmajor danke vielmals verbunden
dieses danke mit der bitte weitere
assistenz unterstützungen zu bekommen
denn wir haben schon in der pipeline
auch die impfungen und eine impf straße
oder mehrere impfstraßen und auch hier
bedarf es der unterstützung wenn wir
heute das jahr zur feier das jahr 2021
schreiben dann wird es ein symbol geben
nämlich ein symbol die verbundenheit
zwischen der militärakademie unterstadt
in wiener neustadt noch stärker
darzustellen und zwar mit einer
offiziellen partnerschaftsvereinbarung
zwischen der militärakademie und der
stadt wiener neustadt wenn sie so wollen
aus einer wilden ehe kommt wird das
sanctus von oben
zuletzt sei mir gestattet in meiner
funktion als aufsichtsratsvorsitzender
der fachhochschule wiener neustadt
festzustellen dass es mich freut dass
schon in der genesis dieses neuen
studiengangs die zusammenarbeit eine
ganz intensive zwischen der
fachhochschule wiener neustadt und der
fachhochschule militärakademie war und
wir werden auch mit gast lektorinnen und
lektoren diesen studiengang entsprechend
mit unterstützen warum weil es für mich
schon ein symbol ist wir sind mit der
fachhochschule vom norden der stadt ins
herz der stadt gerückt in die nähe der
militärakademie
und jetzt sollten wir hier auch dieses
diesen studiengang und die bisherigen
studiengänge in der militärakademie
nützen um synergien zu schaffen aber
auch um gesellschaftlich sozial und
persönlich hier einander näher zu
bringen
und wenn das einander näher bringen so
aussieht dass man dann in der freizeit
in meinem wohnzimmer nämlich nicht immer
einen echten wohnzimmer sondern in der
innenstadt sich zusammenfindet und in
der post pandemie all das genießt was
hier angeboten wird so würde mich das
freuen in diesem sinne hin von
rauchenden schloten zu rauchenden köpfen
ich wünsche den rauchenden köpfen viel
erfolg denn wenn sie ausgedacht haben
sind sie wesentlich für unsere
gesellschaft für die weiterentwicklung
dieser gesellschaft und dafür ein
herzliches dankeschön an dichter
bundesminister ein herzliches dankeschön
an die ich ja generalmajor an die
verantwortlichen general wörgötter bzw
an die geschäftsführung der
fachhochschule wenn der neustadt ich
wünsche viel erfolg
herzlichen dank der general sehr geehrte
frau bundesministerin sehr geehrter herr
bürgermeister ich bin jetzt kurz das
angetan
meine damen und herren geht es auch so
ob der aussage welche summen in
absehbarer zeit hier in die
infrastruktur am campus der
theresianischen militärakademie
investiert werden und sie können sie gar
nicht vorstellen wie dankbar wir sind
sie werden wirklich das beste heraus
machen ganz ganz vielen dank die
japanische militär gedient hat im juni
2020 im wege der fachabteilungen von der
frau bundesministerin den auftrag
erhalten diese studiengang zu entwickeln
mit dem ziel des kdfb für informations
und kommunikationstechnologie
warum brauchen wir diese offiziere
digitalisierung informationstechnologie
computerisierung alles bausteine die
immer mehr zu dem begriff selber führen
was auch immer man das selber versteht
diese faktoren bestimmen unsere heutige
gesellschaft und bestimmen immer mehr
streitkräfte und den einsatz der
streitkräfte
was meinen wir damit sie sehen hier ein
bild in die zukunft gerichtet gesprächen
von waffeneinsatz systemen von führungs
informationssystemen von sensoren und
von wirkungs mittel diese wirkungs
mittel müssen nicht immer nur legal sein
sondern können auch im
elektromagnetischen spektrum stattfinden
deswegen ziehen wir auf diesen kg offis
hier kurz dargestellt
love is here oder auch eine offizieren
die eben in der lage ist all das zu
beherrschen und gas zu vernetzen um die
einsätze entsprechend zu unterstützen
wenn sprechen wir an wenn suchen wir
versuchen junge damen und herren die
offen sind die sich der zukunft stellen
die bereit sind in österreichischen
punkte sehr und dem österreichischen
bundesheer zu dienen die bereit sind
ihren einsatz im in- und im ausland zu
versehen und damit auch ein hohes maß an
flexibilität und mobilität erforderlich
ist ganz kurz der überblick wie sieht
dieser ausbildung zum ekd office hier
aus in summe sprechen wir von vier
jahren ein jahr lang wärter ausbildung
drei jahre studium was bedeutet das
erste jahrgang werte ausbildung
wir sprechen hier von der militärischen
basisausbildung das lernen von waffen
selbst und kameradenhilfe sport diese
ausbildung ist vorliegend autor
es kommt dann im august nächsten jahres
dieses aufnahmeverfahren für den
studiengang und der studiengang stellt
sich wie folgt dar kurzer einblick
wir nutzen wie schon durch die verbundes
ministerin angesprochen die synergien
der jetzige studiengang militärischen
führung welche international hoch
anerkannt ist wir nutzen die durch den
bürgermeister angesprochen die
kooperation mit der fachhochschule
wiener neustadt und natürlich auch die
expertise unserer fachschule der
sogenannten führungsunterstützung schule
die in wien diskutiert ist erlauben sie
mir nur ganz kurz einige einblicke in
den studiengang selbst einerseits das
thema führen führen führungsverhalten
als die basis für diese ausbildung und
das in all den einsatzorten selbstschutz
sei es angriff sei es verteidigung und
ziel ist immer der die kette offizier
der eben in der lage ist auch diese
führungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
dieser studiengang wie der name schon
sagt hoch schulische ausbildung wir
sprechen hier von taktik einsatz von
patronen größenordnung 1000 soldaten
sogar finnen wiederum in den das militär
kennzeichneten operationen wir haben
großen anteil an militär pädagogik
rechtslage aber auch fremdsprachen das
thema körperliche fitness hat in dem
studiengang ebenso eine bedeutung sport
komponenten im gebirge oder aber auch
das thema fallschirmspringen und wie
auch durch die frau bundesministerin
schon dargestellt diese vertiefen
gebiete im bereich der informations und
kommunikationstechnologie alle aspekte
der sicherheit datenbanken
programmierung netzwerke elektronische
kampfführung also wenn sie so wollen die
basis für eine weiterführende selber
kompetenz wie geht es da wie kann es
nach diesem studiengang weitergehen auch
durch die frau bundesminister hahn klar
dargestellt einerseits die möglichkeit
an der landesverteidigungsakademie zu
gehen dort den masterstudiengang zu
absolvieren oder aber auch ziviler
bildungseinrichtungen zivile
fachhochschulen um eben dort dann sich
weiter auf diesem gebiet zu vertiefen
wir haben einige unterlagen aufgelegt
für weitere details darf ich sie
einladen auf unserer homepage www
milliarde nachzusehen und meine bitte
vielleicht auch in ihrer
berichterstattung die am kommenden
wochenende stattfindet der beste
anzusprechen wo der anträge der bürger
da dann entsprechend weiterführende
informationen präsentieren wird und
gemeinsam mit ihnen stehe ich für fragen
zur verfügung und nochmals von
bundesministern vielen dank für das
vertrauen das sie uns aussprechen mit
diesem studiengang und haben als dank
für die anerkennenden worte ich kann sie
nur so zurückgeben
herzlichen dank der suche sind nun
wieder fragen dafür meine hand zeigen
bieten damit das mikrofon zu ihnen
kommen kann damit man in der frage auch
hört wo hat denn das bundesheer bisher
diese fachkräfte her in den in den
verschiedenen positionen wo werden
wurden die bisher ausgebildet und wie
sie wurden bisher ausgebildet in der
waffengattung führungsunterstützung eben
an dieser führungsunterstützung schule
in gehen und man hat eben erkannt das
ist zu wenig wir müssen hier noch tiefer
hinein gehen die materie und deswegen
wird eben nachgesteuert mit diesem
studiengang gibt es mehrere fragen
ja wenn es keine weiteren fragen gibt
dann sage ich herzlichen dank für kommen
und beendete pressekonferenzen